[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the creek in the cave
at this time we ask that you turn off
all cell phones and please refrain from
any photography we also ask that you
refrain from heckling the comedians
during the performance
and now please give it up for your hosts
for the evening they're very funny and
talented mr hans kim
thank you
good to be here my name is hans kim uh
this is the show keep it going for
yourselves
[Applause]
wow what a wonderful audience we have
my name is hans kim the show will is
started it's currently going on
a little less feedback would be nice in
the monitors
so what happens is i draw from the
bucket and then two people come on stage
and they go on a little date for a
minute and then afterwards we interview
them and then get to know them a little
better and maybe do a little roasting
about
how like they're poor or something
we had one guy who barfed on his
sexual partner so
we made fun of him for that and the the
roasts were flying for that one for that
guy
uh but we're gonna have a good time uh
at the other people show
it's called that so that you can tell
people you're going to see other people
and then they'll think you're going on a
date
but it's just a show where you get to go
on a date so i guess it's not really a
lie
feedback is good the lighting is good
and the stage is all set for a guest you
might have seen her on kill tony give it
up for christina mariani
[Applause]
[Music]
being introduced to with royalty free
music
so we don't get pulled off youtube how
do you feel being live on youtube
tonight
good
okay
can we get less feedback
the feedback is sort of
not ideal
uh but uh how's your dating life like uh
are you uh going out there tenderizing
the austin populace
no the last time i went on tinder there
was a picture of a guy in a diaper with
guns and so i was like this isn't a
dating app for me
sounds like a babysitting app yeah
sounds like that guy has some issues you
should have reported him he's probably
one of the terrorists on january
i don't 6th some people are into like
baby kings is that is just is that just
pedophilia uh
a baby that's pretty much pedophilia
uh luckily everyone here is 21 and up
uh yeah it's just making sure all right
uh none of you got trapped on that one
uh so let's let's go to the bucket and
see who we got coming up first
up on the big stage
uh no lgbtqia contestants today
but maybe next week
i don't think we've ever had two lgbtqia
date testings we just had two dudes in
the straight bucket go up together
which might happen
tonight um this first guy coming up is
brad brockman
going on a date with sandra
[Applause]
let's see it go down
brad brockman of course hilarious
stand-up comedian
uh
proud member of
antifa or something
uh give it up for sandra and brad
brockman hello
hi uh sandra testing hello hi it's nice
to meet you i'm brad nice to meet you
sandra
sandra oh excellent nice to meet you
where are you from sandra from chicago
originally yourself i am from san
antonio texas okay what brought you up
to austin
depression
fair
all right what brought you to austin is
that from san antonio san antonio gave
me depression no new york uh city gave
me depression
i have and i understand that yeah the
first day i went to new york i thought
it was trash day and my friend then
described to me no every day is trash
day up here new york is trash yeah sorry
new york
uh what brought you to austin i was in
dc so similar to you i was ready to get
out of the city that was all about
careers and to a city that was much more
fun are you
a very political person would you
describe yourself as such i am not i was
one of the only people not going out to
watch political debates oh okay this is
exciting every night yep what about
yourself uh as far as super political
person no i i'm uh fairly apolitical
okay
yeah yeah that's cool we've just loved
dc then
yeah that's what i've heard yeah i've
avoided and time
give it up for these two a political
daters
so you you guys both came to austin what
how long have you been here sandra
sandra i've been here two and a half
years two and a half years so we'll call
it three now so you were here before the
pandemic i was here before the pandemic
nice
and how has the city changed during the
pandemic you know you very clearly
decide who
is going to be in your bubble or circle
or not
i will say it adds another layer
to the swiping right because as soon as
you find someone who disagrees with the
vaccinated not vaccinated thing it's
pretty easy to swipe accordingly yeah
talk about that
how do you feel about it i mean
i believe in science so i'll let you
infer what you will whoa i'm so
political i thought you were a
politician no do you know what i have
belief so i'm not gonna you know fight
to the nail but yeah so i hope that
we're all in your bubble right now
because technically we're all swapping
air we're all swapping we're all in each
other's you believe in science
yeah brad do you believe in science
yeah that's why i didn't get the vaccine
correct
i'm just kidding you're an anti-vaxxer
i'm not an antivirus the only antifa
member that's also an anti-vaxxer who
came to austin yeah this is a wrong city
bud
go put on your diaper and hold up a gun
we're very proud here we got a lot of
proud boys in austin i'm just joking i'm
not a proud boy
he's a political apolitical he's an
anarchist i did get the vaccine for your
sake sandra oh thank you only for you
yeah absolutely that's a requirement
apparently i canceled a date because
someone didn't have a vaccine and my
friend was like should just go it's a
red flag yes and help do your you know
do your stupidity yeah you should go on
first dates at cvs there you go
uh sandra so if you had to take a wild
guess what kind of vaccine do you think
uh brad got and what do you think that
says about him as a person you think
he's a johnson johnson type of guy no i
think he's i think he's a pfizer dude oh
pfizer
is a guy
why why did you assume that he was a
pfizer guy oh no i got pfizer
so i just threw that one out i figured i
had a roughly
you know 40 shot at least with the
pfizer maybe more like 60 just simply
with supply demand and
the fact that you know j j had less
results but we're getting into super fun
vaccine territory now it is super fun uh
brad what vaccine would you guess that
saunder had if you didn't know she
already got pfizer oh well if i didn't
know uh because of her like super
vaccine uh pro-vaccine status i would
guess johnson and johnson it seems
johnson johnson that's kind of an insult
in the vaccine community
okay it's the least commitment
brad this date is not going off to a
good start you called her a johnson
johnson recipient i mean johnson johnson
that's almost worse than anti-vaxxer i
mean it might be i think it is worse
than antivirus because then you have
like that like because you tried but you
failed you know anything just don't even
try
but i think is sandra calls uh that one
time she had a threesome johnson and
johnson as well
that was their last name what else was i
supposed to call him the johnson
brothers
sounds like a square nightmare
uh on drugs or is it the vaccine
she's hopped up on stimulants
she's caffeine oh caffeine caffeinated
good one
where do you go get uh coffee from
depends where my dates go where brad
where did you take your dates to get
coffee if you had if you had to go on a
coffee date with a date uh
i'd have to say starbucks because if you
turn your nose up to starbucks then uh
you know it's just a little that's a
little too serious i think there's a
little bit of new york in you still
try going on the east side and
suggesting starbucks oh yeah no i i work
in a coffee shop that would uh turn its
nose up to starbucks but you work in a
coffee shop i do okay i think we need to
dig into this more yeah sandra what
question do you have for this coffee
barista uh
most popular drink you make
oh a vanilla latte
that is my drink so oh
you guys are made for each other he can
make you the drink that everyone else
gets
that's true
so much for saying i'm unique on dating
apps
do you say that on dating oh the most
vanilla latte date i feel like the
vanilla latte would though
christina what are you what are your
thoughts on this beautiful couple on
stage right now
will you show her your johnson later
that's all i got
you got to buy me a shot first ah okay
i'll let her buy you a shot maybe it'll
be j and j okay do you think that jay
and james spit in his drink
right
christina mariani explaining to us why
we have the highest covet cases in the
world
we're just swapping spit out here
um so uh where what coffee shop do you
work at brad
what does it rhyme with you know when
this air is probably none
yeah uh
well it's a local austin dallas buzz
mill
no it's starbucks
starbucks hit the nail on the head it's
absolutely the local side east side
north side east side east side okay
do it that narrows
i think we need three guesses
three guests
you've been here three years you have a
good lay of the land what is your first
three guesses
is it okay so brew and brew
no greater goods
no
[ __ ] y'all help me out
what do i look like
an idiot
[ __ ] i don't think he looks like a flat
track guy come on y'all
and we're ran out of guesses your
employment is a secret you still have
your job thank you we can't uh do an
advertisement for you and get your boss
more money but you gotta pay me more
first
maybe next time we get a sponsorship
from your uh employer
get you on here making us drinks
uh so let's do a little improv exercise
let's say that brad is an employee at an
unnamed coffee shop and you come in for
a drink okay let's see how it goes down
hello brad
how did do you know my name
you have a name tag
oh i'm sorry i'm a
little high haven't had your caffeine
yet today i have not a
second favorite drug um
what uh what would you like to drink
most basic drink ever
oh
yeah you mean
uh watching i got you yeah that seems
about right
uh what was your name again
samantha
samantha you do look like a man have you
ever seen sex in the city i have i don't
know if that's a compliment or an insult
though how do you take it i don't know
do you like sex
and scene
brad next though
i think you're gonna get fired from your
job at the coffee shop
like i said you know what like that's a
legitimate question if i said samantha
yeah do you like sex
have you watched sex in the city no i
haven't deeply offended that they did
not bring back samantha i think that's
why sex in the city the reboot has no
sex in it sounds like you drink vanilla
lattes i believe you're 100
uh so brad uh
do you do you meet a lot of uh eligible
young bachelorettes at your job at the
coffee shop and how does it usually work
out that's why he's been fired as he
gives out free vanilla lattes to
everyone and ask them if they like sex
brad and the number yeah the phone
number that's question mark if it is
samantha
yeah so that was strike two the samantha
comment right
johnson johnson samantha
what's strike three gonna be
brad are you drinking water
no there's some bubbles it looks
carbonated it looks like there's
probably some alcohol in there okay can
we get some cocaine in there or
something you're very low energy right
now really oh damn uh okay i'll pep up
uh yeah no i when i meet hot singles at
the coffee shop uh
i just hand them their coffee and try to
be as polite about it as i can be
honestly i think it's weird for like
employees to hit on customers
yeah
so weird i would support that
someone once wrote their number and
their name on my chipotle bowl a little
bit creepy chipotle that was in college
i will say that was so much better than
getting bought a drink i was like sweet
like if we could make this a regular
thing like i could get you did you get
the bowl for free no
i wanted a call back right yeah yeah he
made you pay for the honor of getting
his number yeah right this will be nine
bucks
for my digits two dollars more for
guacamole yeah exactly
you said that uh you're a political what
is the most controversial political
opinion that you hold
sandra
it holds a lot of them and it depends on
the person in terms of i personally
think we need to make abortion legal
whoa controversial i know
you have the right to choose what a
lefty over here this is far left
politics
so you think abortion should be legal
something that's legal in pretty much
every modern country in the world right
now
um do you think
except texas i said modern so
uh do you think that uh
you know we should be
masking up
yes i have a mask in my purse but you
know typically take them off for dates
but depends on the date there's
definitely some that i've been thankful
that we have masks because i'm like this
is awesome i can put this on and avoid
any potential kiss like
mask yeah so it's a nice shield it's a
kiss shield so do you want to kiss him
is that why you don't have your mask on
she's ready
lips are in kissing mode nope both of
you no i i'm not a pta person
not cause that's the only reason brad
what's the most controversial opinion
that you hold
political opinion
um
i don't think that everybody should get
the right to vote
advocating for an oligarchy
no we need to based on iq
well i don't feel necessarily qualified
to determine what it should not be based
on or not but um
there's a lot of people that shouldn't
vote
like
that's fair i don't know
if you prefer the reboot to sex in the
city to the original sex in the city you
should probably shouldn't be voting
we're having sex apparently
yeah i guess you don't right i think
that if you're a dude and you have an
opinion on sex on the city you shouldn't
be able to vote
i think that's i think you should be
able to vote but you know
it shouldn't count
how do you know so much about sex in the
city
uh
i
lived in new york for a little while and
uh
i was in a relationship for uh too long
with somebody that watched sex and stuff
he did samantha
yeah why the hell did it end
oh fail
yeah i i couldn't watch the reboot you
couldn't watch the reboot that's why it
ended yeah and then your relationship
didn't get a reboot
nope it ended on the first season yeah
after the pilot they just canceled it it
was too much i could make so many sex in
the city puns i'm really biting my lip
right now if you had to assign a
character to brad which character would
it be
skipper
what is skipper christina you know
skipper she sees that i've seen all sex
in the city
she sees the skipper yeah i yeah
samantha i was gonna say oh for him
yeah not no i i still think skipper
is samantha homeless man on the show
on the new show maybe
uh what uh what makes you think that
he's like a samantha i don't know i feel
like samantha's like the free-spirited
one right that
gets around and gets all the guys i feel
like you get a lot of guys
i have a lot of offers definitely yeah
popular with the men um i mean he's a
barista so
yeah that's awesome dude
you get all thinking dudes
uh you said free spirited i uh
i don't really see him being that free
of a spirit he reminds me more like an
eeyore or like
uh that would be a miranda insects in
the sea term
yeah
uh what would you say
sandra is brad do you think that she's a
samantha or a skipper um you know i
don't know the characters well enough
but it's uh
the brunette one charlotte charlotte
okay
i think that's a compliment i'm a fan of
charlotte you strike me as a shark
you're clapping a little bit of wait no
charlotte i have no idea a little bit of
miranda a little miranda i think well
miranda miranda ran for governor of new
york is that right
yeah yes yes
she did
yeah oh interesting
cynthia nixon yeah a little cynthia
nixon okay nice but mostly
charlotte okay so a charlotte that got
the johnson and johnson and now we see
charlotte's like the sweet one that ends
up marrying
like the doctor i think no the lawyer
the lawyer well hopefully
you get caught in charlotte's web and
you have a wonderful dating uh history
together and you guys make lots of
little babies
give it up for brad and sandra they're
gonna get married hopefully
what a wonderful first date we had on
the show
yeah i think there's something there
yeah
i feel like brad was a little low energy
and saundra was very high energy so it's
good yin and yang
yeah maybe we'll get you up here again
to do some more improv oh she's done
she's done for the night let's uh
let's pull the last woman out here if
you guys want to sign up please do
there's a there's a lack of women on
this show
maria is that's your name
oh yeah
yeah we can do that you guys want to
come up together
maria and ben all right let's get maria
and brent up here give it up for maria
and ben
[Applause]
you guys uh want to sign up later or
just go on a date with one of these
many names in here
all right give it up for maria and ben
going on a date
for the up tenth time
feels good though
come here often ben
um no first time
well we were here for a uh
cornhole tournament
that is true
so fun
wait are we supposed to acting this is
our first date or
no just talk to each other okay
well we had a lot of fun trying to sell
clothes today didn't we
it was pretty much a fail we tried to
sell some of our clothing and no one
wanted it no one wanted it well people
wanted it the first time but only 17
dollars worth of
sure which we spent on this show so
you're welcome hans
but um
yeah what was your favorite part of the
day
um favorite part was playing pool
definitely
playing pool yeah we did do that poorly
also
yeah we quit halfway between it
but that's the only because pavement
called to tell you that they weren't
taking our clothes again yeah accurate
and time
thank you guys for going on a date in
front of us
give it up for maria and ben
what a wonderful couple
beautiful maria and ben selling clothes
together
you guys work at goodwill or are you
guys
really down on your luck she pretty much
does live a good well she probably goes
to goodwill like
bi-weekly right
well it was a lot during the pandemic
just like anything to feel something
because goodwill actually has an online
store so it was pretty bad she made me
like change her password because she
bought so much stuff at goodwill there's
goodwill has an online feature it does
yeah and it's like it's ebay so you can
have no idea
bid on things it's like the shittier
version of amazon
it's like for poor people you can you
can find some good stuff though you can
find some good good stuff yeah
so uh do you buy it online and then you
go pick it up at the store no they ship
it it's like uh you know
amazon
so you want the uh close of goodwill
uh and the prices
uh why don't you just buy clothes on
amazon like is it
a moral stand no
not a moral stand it's just like
well tell me if this is a moral stand
there's just like so many good things
that already exist why buy
things that you don't yeah
haven't been used yeah yeah
i get i get both sides i i get both
sides but yeah what better way to
celebrate the pandemic then sharing
clothes with strangers
[Laughter]
that sounds completely hygienic
i buy new clothes don't worry
thank god someone in the relationship is
uh
getting clean
what's the dirtiest thing that you've
done in the you know like is that did
you come to
from like a hard night working in the
mud pits
wow and did a shower and then just got
in bed and got your boots everywhere i
probably shower too much yeah i show her
twice a day you look like you showered
twice a day it looks shiny
yeah it's like that's why she said
opposite attract i shower she doesn't
shower oh she doesn't shower
and she wears clothes from goodwill
this is not a very flattering image that
we have so far definitely not
flattering she no she has some good
things also what is your favorite thing
about maria
my favorite thing yeah um she's
definitely more social than i am so
whenever like conversation starter she's
usually the one to do it so i like how
she's a
great personality she was carrying the
date she definitely was
she was doing all the talking and uh
yeah it was confusing she started asking
like
are we on our first date or like what's
happening right now i was kind of
improving a first date but i don't think
you were like totally picking up on yeah
he's a little autistic
that's why he showers twice a day
what's your favorite thing about ben
over here
oh my gosh um
my favorite thing about ben is probably
just how like kind and
calm he is all the time very calm
like
ben
i haven't met a person really that ben
has
ever been mean to like i feel like
i'm the mean one
so you're very social
and mean so you're like going up to
people and then being like and [ __ ] you
and just moving on to the next person
yeah sometimes a little too mean like
like one time you got your nails done
and then you started yelling at the
the person afterwards
were you uh stopping asian hate or
starting it
no in dc it was something with uh it was
a while ago but you
i don't know maria looks horrified right
now
that
yeah that doesn't
it doesn't feel totally right but
ben maybe you need to take another
shower uh
you're pissing off your girlfriend what
happened i'm curious now you went into
dc you uh got your nails did and then
you started berating someone apparently
i don't think if i'm remembering what
you're remembering
it was a minor issue it wasn't yelling
but it was
it was just a customer complaint you get
beat at home men
on the couch tonight
i recognize the look
how did it go down to your recollection
um
i think i if anything i feel like i was
just like mad at you for the thing
for like the that was me wait okay like
i thought the weight i think that was it
you're right yeah but i
i feel like i was mad
like i didn't get mad at
whoever worked there i feel like i
actually just got mad at ben ben you
[ __ ] up man i need to take a shower
yeah
like she's mad at someone i don't know
who but she keeps yelling she wasn't mad
at you
maybe it was
how long have you guys been dating
three years
and you guys uh came with her with uh
your friend from dc you guys all lived
in dc
yeah
oh now she is yeah
so how did you guys all live in dc and
then move here together you didn't even
realize that she was from
no i actually did not know sandra that
was the first time i knew that yeah
you guys all lived in d.c together she
came here three years ago you guys have
been dating three years yeah what part
dc do you live in
all right so virginia chevy chase
in maryland so in dc they name their
neighborhoods after celebrities
that's so weird chevy chase
uh yeah i mean i want to go move to the
neighborhood in dc called the billy
crystal
to move to crystal city yeah the crystal
city crystal city oh it's not a meth
reference
it's just a celebrity
so what is your advice to people just
starting to date as a three-year veteran
in the game do you guys have anything to
say for uh maybe sandra and brad out
there who are gonna start a beautiful
new relationship
i feel like it depends where you are in
your life let's say you're both
apolitical
and
both vaccinated just be honest
honesty yeah
that's my advice is just be honest
unless unless unless it's about her
getting mad at a nail salon yeah then
lie out of here
make up false memories to gaslight your
your partner
um
what do you guys will never be honest
yeah don't ever lie out of your teeth
uh so what do you what do you guys uh
what brought you here tonight you guys
wanted to see other people go on dates
and
just rekindle
that old memory of we went to a kill
tony show and then uh we saw you on and
then uh
we heard you did the show here so we
decided to stop by nice thank you for
coming of course
i uh
yeah i feel like uh that's awesome that
you guys came
and uh
yeah now i feel pressured i mean
but also like you know i lived in new
york and um yeah she loves comedy so in
general yeah so
trying out the you know the local comedy
scene comedy clubs yeah thank you for
supporting local comedy
we all very much appreciate that
comics in the back going crazy
um what is your favorite uh comedy bit
that you've heard
um
in austin or ever just ever oh um
uh wow anything that like tignataro does
is prob is just super good um i think
she did the bumblebee joke
uh
no my favorite tignatara one is when
she's at the party with her friend and
they pretend to lose their dog and so
she's just crawling around the party
looking for a fake dog that doesn't
exist
that's a good joke that's funny yeah so
let's do a little improv exercise let's
say that
ben you're the host of this party and
then maria all of a sudden starts
looking for a dog and she's crawling
around the floor and you don't know
what's going on and you think that she
might be mad at you or something
uh and action okay
um
annie
annie
uh what are you doing over there it
doesn't matter annie annie
is is annie your dog um
yeah she is but i can't i can't find her
anywhere and it feels kind of like it's
your fault
why is it my fault um
this is your party isn't it annie yep
isn't annie your dog
well
aren't we your guests
that's a good point
well typically yeah what would you do
i like what would you do to find a dog
um
i have a treat
a treat yeah what kind of dog would you
like peanut butter you have you just
have peanut butter yeah
this is my house i have peanut butter do
you have it
is it in your pocket or what do you yeah
right over here some peanut butter you
keep peanut butter in the bushes that's
kind of weird uh no that'd be my kitchen
but um
but yeah well your kitchen has a lot of
bushes and there's a bush in your
kitchen you should probably get that yes
checked out yes and yeah well i shower
so much i don't have time to clean my
kitchen so okay
why do you shower so much
um i'm apparently i'm autistic so that's
why you know i shower quite a lot well
that's okay
um
and scene
hopefully i give it up for that improv
exercise they did they just transported
us
to another world that was awesome i
thought you were going to start smearing
the peanut butter on a certain part of
your body today
that's why you shower so much
every day you get some dog to lick us
yes
um
do you guys have any pets
oh that's so that was like a really true
to life sort of uh you know it hit home
yeah that was that's very realistic you
guys are using things from your real
life to inform your uh acting
uh true true thing that you did
so
where do you guys think that your next
date will be just the two of you going
out to hit the town what do you guys
like to do together
um
well we love ramen that was kind of it
was either ramen or this yeah we chose
this over ramen so so i think ramen is
on the menu so i'm worth more than three
dollar ramen
um it's kind of expensive ramen yeah
okay
it's about the same as the show
well you can do both you could get ramen
after this
we could cook you ramen in the back
it's pretty
um you guys uh
you guys
like uh
vaccinations love
love vaccinations i've been getting
vaccinated since i was a baby
vaccines up in here you were brainwashed
from an early age
uh what's your favorite vaccination
um
well
i'm really familiar with the flu vaccine
so that's a big do you get it every year
every year yes
it's a little uh
you know autistic
matches
um
i haven't gotten the flu so
uh so are you guys both vaccinated yes
yeah and boosted
recently yeah what's uh what vaccination
did you get let me guess
moderna
true bowl was my booster
booster probably a little side of pfizer
yeah
100
that's what uh yeah i mean you seem very
uh vanilla latte if you know what i mean
seems very uh by the book no sugar in my
coffee yeah just straight up pfizer up
in there just visor black
what do you have to say to this lovely
couple that's been together for three
years
what do you do to keep it interesting
we did do a staycation so that helps i
met in bed
i mean we got a hotel room as opposed to
did you [ __ ] the hotel room
we [ __ ] in the hotel room
change up the bed keep the same position
the bed's different it's it's not the
same position
so uh
different wall
you want to keep asking these questions
because i feel like if i do it it's a
crime oh
yeah like what position not like
that you were facing the bed but like
on the uh not facing them what position
is your favorite would you say oh
um wow i don't know if i can answer that
answer that
um in the shower just so many i don't
like any of them either
[Music]
with a sheet in between you and a hole
cut
out wow
well that's new so we can we can try
that and report back
none of you are jewish i'm guessing
oh
nice then you should definitely do that
that's what they do right i think it's
mormons oh that's amish
i have no idea what we're talking so
you're a jewish person named maria
yes wow my mom converted to judaism
before i was born so my mom and my dad
aft you know when i was born were both
jewish
so you're jewish why didn't you think i
was jewish
well i did
yeah you seem pretty jewy
[Laughter]
ben what's your mom's name and why is it
rebecca or mordecai no it's marie
marie
so marie maria
is that yeah
does he ever say his mom's name in bed
no no
that has never happened but he probably
thinks about her
he is jewish
nice well give it up for this lovely
couple and ben's mother
a threesome from afar
from israel
uh so let's get a straight couple up
here
uh we got two women in here wow what an
awesome thing the more women the better
giuseppe giuseppa
giuseppa
and let's see who she goes on a date
with
william willman
let's see willman a man
a person who identifies as a straight
man willman is there a woman in the
audience
well giuseppe i'm sorry but willman is
not here we're gonna get another man up
here luckily there's too many of them
uh grant thorburn
give it up for grant
he's gonna go on a date with giuseppe
just sepa josepa giuseppa giuseppa
giuseppa and grant
both start with g
hi guys nice to meet you nice to meet
you as well
all right
where'd you get your sweater from
okay we were talking about pavement
earlier this is actually a pavement
acquisition as well it's a pavement
piece yeah it is so are these shoes
wow flex how many times a week do you go
thrifting
not enough i actually don't go shopping
at all i'm kind of fearful of it why
i have like really bad taste and nothing
ever fits so it's just like an anxiety
attack every time i go in there that's
sad i know
but eventually
i get someone to go with me and help me
and it all ends up working out as you
see yeah no it looks great who helped
you this time so um i've made some
friends since i came to austin a group
of guys i met while i was at native
hostel they all have really good fashion
all super nice they all like seem to
look like they know what they were doing
so i was like hey would you all take me
out to go shopping sometime
and we spent like three hours doing it
but i got like three pieces of clothes
did y'all kiss after no
but uh boring
yeah it did result in um
a dinner kind of date i didn't really
know it was going to be a date until i
was kind of there like you know because
dudes sometimes we you know grab a bite
to eat and talk about our lives about
our jobs or something yes you friends
your friends
some sometimes uh
yeah i thought it was a friend kind of
date and i think he wanted more than
that and uh yeah i was kind of tricked
into a date but end time
tricked into a date again
you signed up for the show and now
you're on a date give it up for grant
and giuseppa
what a wonderful date you say that uh
you don't have any taste and none of
your clothes fit
they do not
uh
i mean the taste you can work on
uh what are you like too large for your
clothes you go to big and tall it's yeah
it's kind of complicated so i used to
weigh 50 pounds more
and i wouldn't buy any clothes for the
longest time because it was like
fluctuating a lot just throughout my
life like high school so you'd just be
naked yeah i just go out naked or i wear
really lazy stuff sometimes like nike
shorts
tennis shoes stuff like that how'd you
lose your weight um i was like at a
i was at a sales conference in vegas and
they have this place called heart attack
girl or heart attack burger and like if
you weigh a certain amount you get like
a free meal so i was getting really
close to that weight i was like ooh okay
we got to stop so i hit up some friends
who run
and they started taking me out kind of
babying me see it all kind of involved
someone basically holding my hand so
promo
good old capitalism
[Music]
so if you weigh a lot then you get it
for free
yeah exactly that sounds horrible wait
so you run that sounds awful well i i
used to so this is the fluctuation part
so once i lost the weight i was like way
too skinny and now i was like the
clothes i had were definitely not going
to fit i had to sell everything and kind
of start again
and then i started going to a gym here
in austin i moved here seven months ago
so i'm going back up so it's an upward
trend what gym do you go to uh it's ford
strength austin sports strength awesome
go check him out yeah ford strength
austin on south lamar behind golden
goose so you can get a drink and get
your gains in yeah maybe go for a date
with grant
he won't see it coming he has no idea
when people are asking him out on dates
if we went on a gym date what would you
do
what would i do on a gym date um
i don't know if we could figure out some
way to get you on a bench press and see
if i could bench you that might work out
right try to bench me what can you bench
um good question don't answer that
what do y'all
think 90 pounds
pretty close
i think you got benched on your high
school football team a lot oh it's very
true i was definitely a skinny nerdy i
still am kind of a hypochondriac too
just so you're a hypochondriac slightly
what was the last thing you thought you
had i mean the real the first real
injury i had was like a broken ankle
but the last thing i thought i had
probably broken neck
you thought you had a broken neck also
football related but i liked i was dumb
so i speared this guy
and i thought that my neck was oh maybe
that's why guys keep trying to take you
on dates because
i'm just sending the wrong messages out
to people i think so you rammed your
head into another guy
and you thought you broke your neck
yeah it's still actually not quite right
it might be a muscle thing but i'm
always like adjusting myself and fixing
my neck i think i need a brace but i
don't want to wear a brace because then
i just look as weird as i am
okay
yeah what a clumsy clumsy dude uh
giuseppe what do you think about uh
going on a date with such a
such a guy that he looks very handsome
now but apparently he used to be a huge
nerd back in high school i still play
skyrim i love it
have you tried to prove your nerdness to
me yeah it works because she doesn't
even know you like star wars too yeah of
course i love star wars that's like you
know mainstream stuff
got to get you into the other things
that what other things
um
i've done one
dnd
game dungeons and dragons with a friend
but it just takes too long only one only
one you probably shouldn't claim it if
it's only one i feel like you're right
posing yeah on my my actual friends have
you ever larped
does going to an anime convention count
like in costume
yes
thank you hans
yes
okay what did you
can you
how did did you make your costume did
you buy it no
again i'm probably kind of a poser i i
bought like an amazon costume
squid games should have gone to goodwill
call back yeah i could probably find
better stuff in there but what's the
kind of the weirdest thing you you've
done
i wouldn't is that the weirdest thing
you've done the nerdiest thing okay
what's the nerdiest thing you've done
sure
nothing
this is the nerdiest thing giuseppe has
done is go on a date with the nerdiest
jock in the world
he's just built different i am but i
kind of like that about me too if i had
to play it that way is i feel like i can
work in both worlds is he a ford truck
hell yeah brother i built different i am
i am built different but i got to know
some more about you so what is it that
you do here in austin what do you like
to do for um like hobbies
i like to roller skate
really yeah i love roller skating that's
a lot of skill i definitely don't have
but i can try you can try do you want to
do like inline skating you know like the
ones all in the line are like quads are
we gonna go like dancing or are we gonna
like race this is kind of like skiing
versus snowboarding right like is the
quads the easier one or is in line
easier
i don't know i don't know anything about
skiing or snowboarding either i'm poor
i feel you have you been skiing or
snowboarding
yeah i tried money
my family did i'm poor but my family's
not yeah
yeah yeah a lot of rich guys say that
yeah
i'm
he's got uh senators he's got uh my
dad's a senator face
oh yes
well who's the the governor of
california someone told me newsome right
yeah yeah that wasn't a compliment when
he gave it to me because everyone hates
that guy but i have gotten that yeah not
for his looks though they hit him for
his policies
uh so
what are you uh what do you what do you
think about uh
dating in austin have you been on a lot
of dates that you knew were happening
yeah so when i moved to austin i was
actually uh in a relationship for a bit
i've been single for about
four or five months now and i have been
just kind of going out meet people it's
been pretty good nothing too crazy but i
got some dating apps now and i'm trying
that but i already hate it so what's
your favorite dating app
well i met my previous girlfriend on
hinge so i'd still have to say that one
worked pretty well but in this area i
think like bumble and tinder are
actually a lot better than they were in
dallas where i'm from if we were to go
on a date in austin do you have anything
you'd want to do like like you know
you're new here yeah well when it warms
up i really like paddle boarding that
way i've never been paddle boarding i've
been for four years i've never been
paddled hey rentals are super cheap how
much five bucks maybe you should am i
right
no
[ __ ] okay it's a little cover though
more than five everything's five bucks
to a rich kid whose dad's a senator well
he's not rich
how much is this car five bucks
give or take you know
maybe
five bucks an hour or 20 bucks an hour
where do you like to go paddle boarding
lady ladybird lake yeah i live a few
minutes from there on south lamar over
by where ford strength austin is nice
spell different
exactly built ford tough
so uh
deal what do you have to say about this
lovely couple giuseppe is very uh great
conversationalist and grant is like very
uh you know he has a lot to say
i think they're great they're both super
hot i don't see how this wouldn't work
out hey yeah if only giuseppe wasn't
here with her boyfriend i am here with
my boyfriend oh that might have worked
out damn son well
it's okay so if she's here with her
boyfriend there's no excuse for any of
you not to sign up
yeah uh you know what he's uh he's not
here but i'm sure he's really pissed off
to to hear that he didn't make it but i
am kind of here on a date tonight she's
actually in the front row say hi she's
really hot i saw her walking it is and i
wanted to get her up on stage but maybe
next time
you're both very attractive people so i
feel like i won this whole this whole
date so
did you uh did you know that you were
going on a date with him or
were you just going out with coffee i
sold her into it yeah
nice that's good that's better than most
of his states apparently
um so what what was with this dude are
you uh bi did were you giving off
bisexual uh signals or was he just you
know fishing you know
the reason why i talked to him was he
was just super friendly and had good
energy and i kind of like hanging around
people with good energy regardless of
what they're into i mean i have to work
on kind of like pumping the brakes and
setting boundaries a bit but he's been
super nice he shows me a lot of austin a
lot and shows me a lot of things i went
into you know inside austin
is his name austin he shows you a lot of
austin
no he's he's not he's not he's not named
austin now okay well i'm glad you're
going on lots of great dates with this
guy um
what uh have you ever had a you know
gay experience or are you completely
gold star hetero i'm gold star but i
think like the more time you spend in
austin it's just like getting constant
pressure from it so yeah being in austin
is pretty gay
you're already
losing yourself i love it you know
that's why i moved here to you know try
new things and go on awesome dates
and meet new people how's it going is
this your guys's first date
good question thursday friday
oh yeah the day before new year's quick
turnaround
oh that's
we have dogs so
my dog did most of the ice breaking
there nice
your dog's going to get awkward later
yeah this better go well or one of
you're going to have to break your lease
yeah you want to go lake tahoe my
parents lake house that i wish i had
yeah third date already did you know he
was rich or are you just finding that
out
yeah good pressure cooker up here i
actually am not rich anymore um
my parents got a divorce and that [ __ ]
went downhill pretty hard after that now
it's just me doing my thing cyber
security just skiing alone
yeah
or with more friends if you and your
boyfriend want to come out with us
sometime we can make this a quad date or
awesome yeah do you want to go on a
double date yeah we do a double date oh
yeah what are you doing should we do
this
yeah we should go paddle boarding now
right now okay should go get some ramen
go thrift shopping some good ideas from
there
yeah there's a great place ramen tatsuya
there's a new speakeasy underneath
another plug tiki tatsuya by the way
speakeasy underneath yeah it's a tiki
bar
uh and the drinks are freaking amazing
you also check it out too it's right
next to where i live so we can put us on
the list what's it called again tiki
tatsuya next to ramen talk sorry one
more time
tiki what sorry
i think him just saying that is cultural
appropriation
everything i do yes
the whitest man ever
giuseppa have you uh ever do you like
dating white men or are they a little a
little too basic for you
is he white you can't see
but he's the first half white guy i've
dated
i don't know i don't think i have a
racial type unfortunately damn i was
trying to catch you being racist there's
always some good content we got to know
more about you and your background did
you grow up here where are you from i'm
from brooklyn brooklyn okay also another
new york person have a friend who just
moved there
i'm not really from brooklyn though like
i was just born there
and then i like moved around a lot how
many places have you lived
five
army fam like military family or no my
dad works for the u.n the u.n okay
so almost kind of same thing yeah
government you're
going to different countries yes nice
what countries
uh cambodia and kuwait and jordan
damn
not the not the most peaceful countries
i guess
we've got possibly not yeah i mean
it's pretty chill
yeah after the khmer rouge i mean like
now it's pretty sure yeah
yeah my dad was protecting the guy who
prosecuted
someone that like ran the khmer rouge or
something
but at the bodyguard okay so he's that's
sort of military like yeah yeah yeah i
mean he's a bonehead like there's
he's not in the u.n for any it's fine
he's the muscle
yeah yeah he's just a big man have you
ever seen the movie taken
yes
and it hasn't happened to me i don't
think i'm pretty enough yet i think i
need to get there you're beautiful
you're very beautiful i think grant is
about to kidnap you yeah
that's how you measure your
attractiveness is how many times you've
been kidnapped
or roofied that's why colombia has the
most attractive women
just keep getting jacked
um yeah i mean uh have you uh have you
ever
you know stopped a crime or helped
someone defend their uh livelihood or
you know you seem like a pretty uh beefy
guy you could step in for that bodyguard
role maybe your dad could get you a job
in the u.n yeah you know what um that
could be a great fit for me i gotta
start taking some mixed martial arts
classes start to toughen up have to get
over the whole hypochondriac thing yeah
maybe stop telling people your weight
used to fluctuate that makes you look
like a real [ __ ] i might have an eating
disorder i eat dominoes don't tell
people you speared a dude in high school
when was the last time you were in a
fight
that was also in high school and it
wasn't even really a fight like i
i was i felt insulted by this kid on the
bus
and
why why did you feel insulted just out
of nowhere oh
we got into fights all the time
who is we
me and this guy named ricky what's his
last name
what's his social
i think it's ricky dress ricky
[ __ ]
so he could just make insult after
insult and i was too dumb to say
anything back oh he was like a roast god
he was a rose god he was and you were
just
like that little kid fluctuating in
weight all over the place spearing dudes
exactly
and then uh
so what did you don't remember why you
felt offended
yeah i don't remember the particular
insult i think usually what triggered me
was some sort of insult about my
intelligence call me a [ __ ] or
something and i was just like you know
what i didn't even directly
challenge him i was just
saying i was upset to a friend of mine
and he went ahead and challenged him on
my behalf
so we had this like semi-fight in some
rich kids backyard so it was big as a
challenge this is like a 18th century
duel i challenge you
yeah so you guys [ __ ]
yeah that was [ __ ]
i'm not [ __ ] i'll fight you you did
we sent a text on those flip phones like
meet me at seven o'clock
dylan davis's backyard ttyl yeah brb
lots of duels in that backyard one got
guy got curb stomp that was for real but
mine was not as cool how did the fight
go down yeah so i watched way too too
many cartoons and anime and stuff so i
was like i'm the bigger guy like i
should give him the first punch
classic error don't do that um
i let him that's [ __ ] yeah i was
mega
he was right dude
yeah um he got punched me and i was
sucking wind really hard
and i got one punch off
he hit me a few more times in the face
then they stopped it
um i think i lost but
he didn't break his hand on my face nice
so
who really won that fight that's a great
move i always like to stop punches with
my face
yeah i got a thick dome and uh
and uh learning disabilities so that all
worked out this is my favorite date
giuseppe's big dome
uh it is
well i mean there's the basic 180d but
it's um auditory processing so like
the reason why it's so easy to go after
me sometimes is like
i have to think about what you said for
a bit like i have perfect hearing in in
sight but when you talk to me it takes
me a few seconds like i have really load
uh processing or like bad internet speed
basically
so dating is probably hard
yeah okay also a good excuse right yeah
i know i just kind of throw out i don't
have to lie much i just kind of say
exactly what's on my mind and it usually
works out but uh not great for roasts no
i've said some dumb things when uh asked
questions what's the dumbest thing you
said
okay i was on a date and this was a bad
one
it was going really well
and
she was saying hey you seem pretty
personable you gotta you got a few
friends and what was the secret to like
why you became a bit more extroverted
after high school
and i was like you know what
it was because i discovered alcohol and
drinking
and i thought that was great that's a
red flag yeah it was i i heard from some
friends after the fact cause i didn't
get that second date they're like you
told her
you are now extroverted because you
learn how to drink and be like
charismatic i'm like yeah that was
pretty honest but it kind of was i went
on one trip with my dad to cabo when we
had money and i was like i could be
whoever i want i could drink and i like
came back i'm like i can do this sober
nice oh it's great liquid courage yeah
that's not that bad
yeah kids if you're listening
yeah that was not bad at all yeah i've
done way worse than that what about you
yeah
yeah what have you what have you all
done
tell us
i called the girl i was dating a nerd
i was like what kind of books do you
like because you're sort of like a nerd
right like you're smart
and then the person sitting next to us
at the cafe coffee shop was like what
the [ __ ]
what about you
um i got really nervous my best friend
tried to set me up with this guy and
then he shows up and he's like super
attractive and i was just not expecting
it at all so
i thought you'd be uglier
you're really throwing me off yeah i was
like what the hell why are you setting
me up with these super hot guys i don't
know what to do um so i was like so if
you could [ __ ] any animal
oh he didn't know what to do with that
okay he was like
something as close to a human maybe like
a monkey and i was like
i was like so you like
aids yeah
he thought it was weird
that is kind of weird the guy doesn't
like comedy it wouldn't have worked out
so did he what did he was he like um i
actually don't like aids uh can we talk
about like your favorite movie or
something
no uh
after that he kind of looked at my best
friend and then afterwards he just
he kind of left like i don't really
remember i just remember that part
because i was mortified and
my friend was like what's that
it's like should i say who doesn't work
it's a good one-two punch
doesn't work like why was your where was
your friend there oh she was there with
her boyfriend i'm always kind of like
third wheeling like because i don't know
maybe my personality it's the best way
to meet people though because i think
the dating apps there's a lot of
catfishing and false personas so meeting
someone in person with a friend kind of
a safety net too if it goes bad for
either of you i guess i noticed you
weren't here with a friend
noticed i wasn't here when i walked in
with a friend you're here with your date
oh yeah she's getting the the next round
for me so i can unload we all need a
samantha or christina right
yeah we've all we've all got people to
support us in this audience which makes
it a lot easier to to go into it it's
like therapy which i also had a lot of
as a kid because we could afford it you
know sounds like you need it now too
yeah but this is therapy right i'm
talking to you you're very good listener
i notice i feel bad because i feel like
i'm doing a lot of the talking but i
kind of want to learn more no this is
how most of my first dates go really so
is it just screening to make sure this
person isn't insane or there's not too
many red flags no they just don't ask me
any questions he wants to ask you enough
questions
that's true too rant is just processing
he hurt you
wait let me think of
just takes him a while
just punch him in the guts
tell me what
what like convinced you that you wanted
to start dating your boyfriend seriously
on our first date um we both didn't want
to stop hanging out
so we kept hanging out until like 9 a.m
the next day when i had to go to work
yeah and he didn't make any like weird
moves and he didn't say anything like
really weird so i was like okay
he's really hot
i believe you i don't see him but step
into the light
gabe where are you
challenge him
with the g is your name
my name is
gabe grant
come over here
gabe do you want to fight grant yeah
yeah get your actual date up here no
come on come on okay she's already
almost up there yeah she's basically a
part of this baby
so gabe how did you uh
what did you guys talk about till 9am
um we watched that movie the [ __ ] uh
the movie about the
tick tick boom you all see that movie no
never seen it uh garfield
yeah yeah spooderman yeah
[Music]
so you guys just watched the movie uh
what did you talk about
oh the movie oh
you guys are film critics we did not
talk about the movie for nine hours
what
we watched that movie and then i uh we
didn't really pay attention because we
were talking about like you know like oh
where are you from what does your
parents do
but what are you doing
um but then we watch parental control
yeah iconic and then love island
no temptation island you guys watch
three movies no these aren't movies
shows have you not seen parental control
no oh it's great did you really watch
all of them or was just on autoplay as
you we did he did not make a single move
i mean you did after i made a joke
smooth criminal here you go we were
watching kitchen island which is about
like not cheating on your partner um
okay let's do an improv exercise okay so
let's say that uh you're on a date and
grant comes up to you guys on a date and
then he just starts uh you know like
something you said offended me uh i want
to spear your boyfriend or something sit
down then because y'all are on a date
and then uh
and then grant offers you like he he
challenges you to a duel in his rich
friend's backyard
and then he offers you the first punch
uh and then
well let's just have him come in and
like i got it
let's let's have let's have you guys
pretend to fight each other so like wwe
i could like insult him real quick but
hey
did i play you in football 20 2013
frisco were you on the centennial i was
12. so
no
don't think so huh
call him a [ __ ] gabe
oh you'll hurt my feelings you're a
[ __ ]
okay
i see how it is the gauntlet has been
thrown down uh i challenge you to a duel
at 7pm
in dylan dave's backyard in starwood
call to get the gate code
and
we use our fists i'm sorry starwood is
hilarious
just the name of the play starwood
yeah you don't know about jerry jones's
neighborhood next to uh the star in
frisco jerry jones
yeah
my mom knows jerry jones
damn
that's like the best like can i speak to
you at a dinner party at a real estate
party
oh really yeah for real yeah gabe is
really good at de-escalating what am i
gonna do yeah and i think your
girlfriend's hot too
well shit's safe but
i mean
i don't think she's gonna come so okay
giuseppa who do you think would win at
arm wrestling
yeah that's what it is this table can't
handle this no
oh my god
his voice yo why would you do that what
would you
let's just do a little game of
rock-paper-scissors
all right well i'm going to take him on
a very straight date afterwards then if
you take her so now
now you stole giuseppe's man you're now
on a date with gabe
oh yeah
you didn't realize it was happening uh
you thought he was just had good vibes
and you love people with good vibes but
now you're on a date gabe made it sexual
so you want to go to pavement sometime
yeah actually yeah what do you what do
you need to get some new clothes for
like shirt shoes anything
i don't know
i actually would go on a date with you
yeah what do you what do you no i did
you're very you you're from a very
affluent community i would like that
yeah i got some connections called the
white community yeah yeah i like that
dude yeah no nepotism is real i don't
know jerry jones so i don't either um
but
i i've been to his club he's got a
secret club over at the star which he's
got his own version of uh maker's mark
if you're in dallas or here that's in
dallas
i don't know what influence he has here
he probably owns a ton of stuff here
okay this is the most awkward straight
men dating ever anyway uh let's just
finish it off with a game of rock paper
scissors for the heart of giuseppe oh
[ __ ]
okay i wanted them to armor so yeah
no arm wrestling is too
primitive
why don't you guys hold hands and you
want to make it interesting you want to
get two for two for one you get both of
them if you win
double or nothing
i don't know dude loser walks away with
no girlfriend
damn loser walks out here empty-handed
yeah and the the winner goes away with
two women [ __ ] they're playing for pinks
yeah paper pinks that's funny [ __ ]
two in the pan gone anyway your girl got
her so you basically already have her
damn dude
i think you guys
i think they're dating now you guys have
to [ __ ] each other
well what do you like to drink i'll get
our next drink what do i like to drink
yeah you like whiskey like um i like
water water water water is very good
water's pretty tight pretty delicious
yeah big water guy okay just do rock
paper scissors and let's see who wins
okay cool all right that's two out of
three or
uh yeah all right
rock paper scissors shoot
oh
[ __ ] grant wins
gabe is uh going to jerk off tonight
please think about uh whatever you want
think about grant
i'll be thinking about it that is sexy
do you guys want to see uh
you guys want to see gabe go on a date
now with grant state says graham went on
a date with carlos
it's only fair that now he goes on a
date with your date
oh you're good she does not consider why
not
you're already pretty much on stage and
you you've been talking
maybe next okay yeah you can sit there
and yeah you guys are on a date now
right in front of me [ __ ] me right
here i just want what are you doing
obviously what are you talking about i
just want you bro
you walked into this i just watched my
girlfriend go on a date with literally
the guy my mom would want me to be you
know what i mean
[Laughter]
i'm the villain in like a movie dude you
don't know what it's like my mom would
love it if i was a tall strong white
blonde guy she would
she would lose it would you like to come
work out sometimes so we can do this
together yeah but i'm not blonde like
we can write your hair
would your mom want you to be a guy that
has neck issues from spearing men
yeah this guy this guy's got some issues
yeah also psychological like there's a
give and take it's not even rich anymore
yeah yeah you're not exactly i'm working
on it you're working on it i've got my
own job
give it up for gabe and grant
this beautiful straight couple
we got time for one more
uh we got one woman left in here
mars g
mars g in the audience
she's a wonderfully funny comedian
is she here
here she comes mars g is going to go on
a date with gareth the menace fisk
oh he left let's get a uh
jeremiah price
jeremiah price up here
going on a date with mars g
local comedian comedian favorite
comedian's comedian hey guys an audience
is comedian she's everyone's comedian uh
give it up for mars g and jeremiah price
so i hear you're funny
kind of sometimes do they pay you
not yet do they pay you for anything for
for what exactly i don't know
like
services sure yeah
what services
um i have an only fan so you know the
word huh really
i have one but i don't make content
oh i see you're you're a subscriber i'm
a subscriber oh word okay yes
to comedians actually
okay good thing i don't have one
mark norman has his uh little podcast on
the only fan so i subscribe to that one
it's a lot of fun nice okay are you from
austin
originally california
but i moved here i've been here for 13
years over in houston went from la to a
ranch
okay have you ever been into a dungeon
um in chains or
just for fun
yeah whatever dungeon dragons were
talking about
i mean you tell me
no i have not would you like to
enlighten me
what's it like in the dungeon you've
been there obviously
clearly clearly
and time
give it up for uh jeremiah and mars g
i'm not a comedian i'm sorry you asked
him if he's ever been in a dungeon
that's kind of a weird question i
thought you would ask him where what
kind of animal he wants to [ __ ] next i
mean it was gonna be a follow-up but you
gotta establish like the dungeon first
you know the dungeon so where do you go
after you take it to the dungeon
to a bedroom at the dungeon
and then to the bed in the bedroom at
the dungeon
there are no keys to the door because
there are no doors
this sounds like an escape room you guys
went for a date in an escape room
intellectually mentally you have to push
a brick in the wall or something how do
you
how do you get out or in there's a front
door
it's not too bad
it's not terrible i feel like we're
getting you're not bewitched by mars
[Music]
i do i have
kind of indirectly though how do you
make money on only fans subscribing to
mark norman's podcast
well that's the only reason i have it
um but i was with some chicks she liked
filming stuff
i was like oh this is for you so sure
and then eight months later i find
myself on the hub
oh you were on there yeah i was on there
oh so she was filming you and her
together it was a little pov dill you
know so you were you're [ __ ] a girl
with a gopro on your head
that would have been way more efficient
yeah i wouldn't have both hands free for
sure so you were holding an iphone
having sex and then you saw your dick on
pornhub i did i was like man that's a
looks like comfortable
why were you watching porn of someone
that looks like you were you looking for
like it looked it was interesting and
then i just like wait i just saw it
scroll through my head it looks familiar
so i started watching i'm like holy [ __ ]
that's
that's me
yeah so i hit her up and she's like oh
uh uh wait and then she cash out me like
800 bucks
nice she's like you're still mad like if
you ever want to hang out again just
[Music]
wait so what looked familiar the the
girl
the bed or like your dick
definitely definitely the mushroom tip
is what looked familiar i look at it
every day so okay yeah you're like that
looks familiar yeah for sure i uh i have
to pee for some reason right now
two-tone you know just can't miss it so
you're uncircumcised i am circumcised
you are serious
it's tough to get a mushroom tip when
you're circumcised imagine if you
weren't circumcised it'd be like a
[ __ ] pagoda
like a
patio
um but you have a mushroom tip dick and
you recognize that what were you
searching or was it on the front page no
i was just going through amateur stuff
because it's real right so yeah you've
done it so you're like apparently um i
love it i've been indoctrinated
[Music]
you're a dungeon master
i like your nickelodeon sweatshirt oh
thanks appreciate it it's bringing back
memories it's actually how i got laid
that time so you know that's crazy oh
yeah yeah
with an adult
[Music]
we were both kids around the same time
so it worked out so watch the same
cartoons you know
when did you lose your virginity
[Music]
i was
20.
why are you laughing i can't tell you a
little man
is 20 is pretty old for he's pretty old
very accomplished sexual god no [ __ ]
the nickelodeon in the box definitely
not
we're one
that's so old
what a nerd i lost mine at 22.
nice so
yesterday how old are you how dare you
oh yeah how old are you i do the roast
here
yeah
um
so uh yeah you lost your virginity uh
you're on pornhub without your knowledge
that's at least your face wasn't in it
right no definitely not no no mirrors or
refractions just you know so just this
you talking about it is online right now
but your actual point is
what would we have to look for to find
it um
bbc destroys tiny white girl
oh my god i love how they exaggerate so
much on porn titles
um
mars uh have you ever been involved in
like uh filming or in uh public displays
of sex
like this guy has or have you been
mostly like
doing it like normal people do it
behind closed doors
uh i wouldn't i wouldn't say i was doing
it like normal people do it i had a
pretty fun summer
oh hot girl summer stand back
white girl summer
um
but uh yeah yeah i don't
uh
you don't put up your partners
on pornhub without their consent yeah my
stuff's not on point hub i'll tell you
that much back in the tumblr days i was
doing a little something something on
there that was fun
but would they allow your stuff on
pornhub was it too much
they probably would it's probably
[ __ ] amateur [ __ ]
if it's
yeah if he can get on pouring up you
could definitely get him pouring up
anybody can it's it's a pretty low bar
it's not like it's [ __ ] uh cnn or
something charms
you can put up put [ __ ] up on i don't
know i've never done it but
you should try it
try and let me know and we'll get all
the comedians into it you're famous now
i'd love to throw all the ladies up
there with you
yeah please sign up i mean it's
it's hard enough to get people to have
sex with me without putting it up on
pornhub do you think you think it'd be
uh easier if i'm like hey this will be
up on the internet forever who wants to
i literally saw you making out with a
girl on new year's like i was in my car
and then you just pop out of nowhere
you're just like aggressive should i not
have said that hans
yeah
i hate it when people talk about how i
make out with chicks
no i i messed up and i put it on pornhub
nice you owe me 800.
um actually i asked her if that was like
normal seems a little low and she's like
it's the round amount
yeah uh 1400
for a 10 minute video hey she gave you a
nice cut yeah she was she felt bad she
thought i was like come after her like
legally
what are you gonna do share your dicks
in every time i would pay 1400 to have
sex
out of me
no with uh your
ex
uh it would be called
white girl gets destroyed by
tiny asian [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's the speed that really does it uh
have you ever kissed an asian man oh oh
you know what i have not got yes no yes
yes
kiss an asian dude jiu jitsu yeah he was
filipino we just kind of bumped into
each other in the middle of it you're
like yeah
yeah
give
where were you going with that mars were
you trying to set up a chaos
i want to come see you do jiu jitsu is
where i'm going oh yeah yeah
yeah jiu-jitsu is fun you got rear naked
chokes uh
triangles like it's it's great yeah
that's all
i want to see for self defense sounds
like your pornhub category yeah sounds
right up my alley so uh what would you
do if you were watching uh him did you
just jiu jitsu would you like cheer for
him like yeah go lay on him more
great trusting
maybe he's just like start throwing uh
dollar bills
800. something like that that's awesome
yeah
jiu-jitsu is just like male stripping it
is so let's do an improv exercise let's
say that uh you're in the midst of a jiu
jitsu battle with a formidable opponent
and mars you're in his corner offering
him advice and encouragement
and action
put it in his ass
it's already there
harder we won't go any further
rip the fabric off
and scene
wow give it up for them they did it
yeah i think i you i don't know you
might have ended up on the wrong date
i don't know oh it's possible yeah
oh yeah i know hey
have you ever been a native hostel
funniest [ __ ] i heard all night you have
great vibes
and that's all grant cares about there's
a lot of nice guys there nice guys huh
yeah i like bad boys i'm sorry
can't you gotta keep up yep
the bad boy
bad boy that lost his virginity at 20.
yeah it was yeah how did that happen how
did it go down
and is it on pornhub
yeah
it was colombian chick i met at a
nightclub and
she's like i'm like you want to dance
with me she's like sorry i don't speak
english i'm like kids by larko amigo
she's like no
but she knew and she understood what i
was saying
so i started dancing with other chicks
she came back she's like okay let's
dance
and then um
she brought me back to her hostel
was it like was there like bunk beds in
there yeah it was like 60 people in that
room
definitely
right now
someone was filming that i guarantee it
were they pretending they didn't give me
money though
no were they pretending to sleep the
whole time or were they just like
shooting you know non-onsen
some of them got out tried to join us
actually the person at the bottom was
like hey
hey
that's kind of like what a dungeon is
like i think you had i think there's
there's an audience in the dungeon yeah
i don't know that oh what he likes he
likes an audience i do like an audience
i feel like you have a name for your
penis
yes tell me
tell me
i call them micro
micro micro yes
microsoft micro micro godzilla i feel
like your head looks like your penis
right now because you said it's two
colors you're wearing a hat and it's
also got the mushroom mushroom top
so i mean thank you for that visual
representation
i like it
oj little oj because the glove never
fits no because you destroyed a white
girl
give it up for this lovely couple thank
you jeremiah and mars g
thank you so much for coming out that
was the show
uh what did you think about all those
dates tonight did you have a favorite
um i think grant and gabe was my
favorite grant and gave the two hetero
men
that
were the only ones that have
incompatible sexualities
um what what did you like about it
i don't know it was just like the most
that left
you
exactly yeah that was kind of how their
date went too
they're like oh i think i like you dude
but you can follow christina mariani on
instagram she's a local comedian she
goes out to a lot of shows uh give it up
for christina mariani
thank you guys so much for coming out
good night drive home safe
first